hello guys my name is Hoshino and
welcome to the fourth episode of the
Sparky game engine series last time we
added input handling so that we could
for example see where this fantastic
Mouse is in our rectangle and out just
awesomely graphically complicated
rectangle here and that's all there
which is fantastic so now we can finally
move on to mass so maths is generally
quite important in game engines and it's
going to allow us to do wonderful things
such as draw things on the screen in the
correct position so let's plan out this
episode as we always do and then next
episode which is going to be episode 5
we're going to come up with a game plan
for pretty much the rest of the 30 days
we have left until Adam down ok but
today we're just gonna plan out this
episode so maths
welcome to Cherry's class so what we're
going to do today is we're going to
implant vectors we're going to implement
vectors kind of in the sense of point
vectors or location vectors rather than
Direction vectors so Direction vectors
we'll do later and by Direction vectors
I just mean they'll have extra well
they'll have extra methods such as dot
and cross product for example but point
vectors are just basically ways to store
a point whether in 2d space 3d space or
Ford or 4d space but they're basically
just ways to draw multiple variables
kind of in one class and be able to do
cool things with them so what we'll do
is we'll make a Veck to class which will
store and which will basically it be a
two component vector so it'll be if
it'll be a vector which has an X and a Y
will have a vector E class which will
have an X Y and Zed and we'll have a
Veck for class which will have an X Y Z
W ok that's it and then in terms of
these will basically be the same class
ok I could really write them as one
class and then kind of be smart about
how I wrap them or template them or
something like that we're not going to
do that any of that fancy stuff for now
I'll keep it simple
because we only got 30 days and then
they want to be writing the the the
maddest maths library around but oh yeah
so we'll do that and then we'll have
methods between them
we'll have obviously our operators so
we'll have stuff like plus minus times
and / right and then I mean we'll have
stuff like what else we'll have we'll
have probably like a an output stream of
red and that's really all we'll keep for
now will have a will have our comparison
operator and that's it so we probably
won't delve into the finer stuff of that
that'll be it
because I don't want to make this video
two hours long Matt for so this is going
to be a matrix fast gonna be a four by
four matrix the the ordering okay and
I'll try and write a bit nicer I think
I'm really quite tired right now
the or the ordering will be column-major
okay because that's what OpenGL takes
obviously having gel pen transpose it as
well but we're going to just do it in
column-major
because we have to choose a major it's
gonna be : major so what that means is
that when we essentially what that means
is that this is how the matrix goes 0 1
2 3 goes down like that 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 15 so basically yes that is
how it goes I believe I might be wrong
let me just double check I always get
confused with this so I just want to
make sure that I'm completely completely
right so yes yes I'm correct good so
that's the plan and then this will this
will be a bit more of a complicated
class all right so right now we will put
in let's see
so we'll start up we'll have a
multiplication I will have an actual
operator as well as our fantastic
multiply function or method rather and
then we'll have
projection matrices such as let's say
will have an orthographic will have a
perspective and etc and then we'll have
some transfer transformation matrices
such as a translation matrix a rotation
matrix and a scale matrix alright and
that is pretty much it cool cool so oh
oh and I always forgot how matrix 4 will
be essentially just just a wrapper for a
flat array which has 16 floats in it of
course because 4 times 4 is 16
ok so that is it that is our matrix and
that is our vectors and that of course
equals matte so let's begin under source
I'm going to make a new item called it's
going to be a header file and it's going
to be called a little cell with it back
to and they're called Veck - ok and
let's see here so pragma wants that I'll
also go ahead and make a well I forgot
to make the folder I want to make so
let's make a folder called maths and I'm
gonna put an s on the end because that's
how I spell it I'll put the vector in
there we'll go ahead and add this to the
awesome namespace of Sparky and then
maths namespace maths
man will make class cold will make this
as drops for now so I'll quickly explain
the difference in the minute because
there really is no difference
striped avec - okay so the difference
between a struct and a class really is
the fact that in a struct the default
visibility modifier is public whereas in
a class the default visibility modifier
is private but from that they have the
exact same functionality they can be
used the same way that's really all
there is to it
now the reason I'm choosing a struct is
because these X and Y's are going to be
public so yes I'm going to choose a
whoops I'm going to choose a struct okay
so yeah pretty advanced pretty awesome
so in this struct we'll have a float XY
okay and then we'll have a vector this
will be just a default constructor which
will take you nothing I'll also have by
the way one thing I want to mention is I
am kind of breaking our convention for
classes and structs and whatever by
having a lower case usually you would
uppercase a class or a struct however
I'm lower casing it and the reason I'm
doing this is so that it matches GLSL s
syntax so in the OpenGL shading language
vectors and math and matrix 4x4 matrices
are expressed like this and like that
okay so basically just matching GLSL so
that we kind of have a consistency
amongst that if you guys want to name it
to uppercase or whatever you can do so
but sparkly it's going to be like this
so this will take an applied to X and
for y and I mean as far as well taking
references low so we've done that what
else are we going to have so I'll
probably start with just having a bunch
of operators and whatnot so for example
we'll have let's plan this out so we'll
have a vector so we'll have ad okay
we'll make both actual methods and
operators for all of these so you'll see
how this works will make the methods
first so we'll take in
so we'll add another vector and we'll do
the same for subtract multiply and
divide okay so what this will do this
will return the current object as well
in case you want to do something like
that you probably won't be this can be
used by themselves by returning kind of
void but will return this as well right
and it will think the current object of
course because it's just returning a
reference to the current object it's not
going to make a new one or anything like
that
those are our basic those are really our
basic functions so let's start
implementing them if I go ahead and make
a new item I'm going to make a CVP file
called Veck to tell CBB I'm going to
include our vector dot H header file I'm
going to grab our name space and push it
in here we will shoot it will dry and
assist us here I'm going to fight it um
so vector vector this is our constructor
I'll set X equal to zero and y equal to
zero for our non default constructor
where we take in a Const float X and a
constant float Y all just set well okay
we'll set this dot X equal to X and this
Y or the Y okay and then we'll move on
to implementing everything else so add
subtract multiply and divide let's grab
that and start implementing it so
addition is going to be pretty basic and
pretty simple and I'm sure you everyone
knows how to do this all we'll be doing
is we'll be grabbing our current mate so
we're just we're doing it to the current
thing right we're going to say X plus
equals other dot X okay and y plus Z
equals other don't why that's really all
there is to it and then we're going to
return a reference to the current object
so we need to dereference it like this
and then that's yeah that's it okay so
we add it and then we returned
our object and I'll tell you why we're
doing this last step in a minute okay
cool oh yeah so like again you can make
this like void for example but I haven't
and you will see why in a minute okay
just because we can still use it as if
it was void but if we want to grab a
reference and apply other other
operations we can do so so we've got add
let's implement the other ones so add
subtract multiply and divide okay cool
so these are literally going to be the
same except this is going to be a
subtract this is going to be multiplied
I'm so lazy I'm just kind of like
drawing a box rats it this is gonna be
divided okay cool and then we're
returning this and that's it so done
yeah pretty basic and it is completely
awesome so let's quickly make an output
stream operator
so in Java there's this an in c-sharp
there's this thing called to string okay
and essentially unless us be all cool
and be like you know what if I make a
vector let's quickly include this so
that we can use it this is main so sauce
maths vector so if I use namespace maths
as well if I go ahead and make it back
to called vector and let's just say I
make it one point zero and one point
zero one people make it 1.0 2.0 let's
get rid of this stuff I can be all cool
and actually print it so I can be like
that right it's the same thing as if you
know in Java if we were to go system dot
out dot print line and we actually give
it an object such as that vector okay
and similar thing in c-sharp if we go
ahead and go console dot write line
and we give it that vector okay so in
order to do that in C++ we just need to
overload this operator and say that you
know what it can take this so to do that
we have to do a few things first of all
it can't be a part a can't be a member
of this class it has to be just a it has
to be outside of this class because
obviously we don't call vector dot C out
we call C out and then we passing a
vector but we also want to be able to
access private functions or privates
private members now we don't have any
private members in this in this case
everything is public but just to be just
to stick with the convention I'm still
going to mark this as a friend so we use
this last episode I didn't really
explain it too much but essentially a
friend just lets you access private
members of a certain class as if you
were in the class right but you're not
so when I do this I'm also going to
include iostream by the way and we'll
probably eventually put all this stuff
into precompiled headers but for now
we'll keep this as is so friend SC do
stream reference and this is this is
just the standard a way to implement an
the output operator the upper stream
operator which you guys can find
anywhere online so a stream operator so
operator overloading is something in C++
that I should probably mention because I
forgot to talk about that in my
introduction to superfluous video
basically we have the ability to change
operators in C++ C sharp can do this to
an extent and Java can do it at all and
see what sports can do it pretty much
everything so what that means is
operators such as plus minus equals x
ampersand divided by modulus all of this
cool stuff we can actually change what
they do okay so in other words if I go
ahead and I add to vector objects
together so I go and say like vector
plus vector we can actually instead of
having to go a vector dot add vector
which is what you would have to do in
Java we can actually test we can
actually customize the functionality of
this plus operator so this is kind of
what we're doing here with this upstream
operator and then we're using the work
the keyword operator here before
we actually mention the operator okay so
we've mentioned the operator now we have
to take in so we're returning a
reference to a stream we're taking in a
stream and then we're taking any
constants to the current object there
was so this is the object that were
actually outputting so contract to
vector all right so let's grab this
again it doesn't really need to be a
friend in this case but whatever we'll
keep it as that all right cool so you
can see it's not part of this class okay
that just because it's this operator and
it shouldn't be far this class what we
basically need to do here is use stream
as if it was because sea out is a type
of output stream so we simply go ahead
and say stream we might want to say
something like I don't know vector or
something
I really don't know what but yeah was
what we say something like the vector
and then maybe a brackets and then we'll
output vector X so if X was private we
could still act if it is public in this
case but if it was private we could
still access it because this is marked
as a friend all right cool so vector X
and then vector dot Y and then we'll
just have put our final bracket and
that's it we won't output an endline
because usually you would do that
yourself here especially if you want to
do a bunch of stuff you just you don't
usually I'll put it in line then finally
we just returned the stream all right
okay and now you can see that if I were
was to run it and I'll just make it
pause like here for example I'll put a
breakpoint down you should see that it
outputs is you can see vector vector and
then one comma two all right great
so that is how that works cool so if I
was to go ahead and say vector dot add
let's just say five and two
well what am i doing better to add five
Oh what do i well how do I even use this
oh it needs to take in a vector
well I destroy my own method and then I
used it incorrectly five and two yeah
and I run this and let's put that
breakpoint here again you can see give
us 6 4 because 1 plus 5 is 6 and 2 plus
2 is 4 all right let me quickly make
this font a bit bigger here like 20
maybe ok yep there we go 64 fantastic so
let's stop that now the cool thing is
because we're attending a reference and
the reason I made it return a reference
to the current object is we can do some
cool stuff like vector dot add dot add
and we can keep doing that and we can
add another 1 1 so instead of being 6 4
for example it is now it should be 7 5
and as you can see it's 75 all right so
we can do some pretty cool stuff like
that and additionally you can do this
yeah you can do this like that it's
pretty much straight away so it's really
it's really um close one then of course
we can subtract it as well
and then we can do whatever we want with
that stuff so there we go
cool right all right awesome so if extra
2 is basically implemented now it would
be nice of course if we were to use some
operators okay
such as you know plus minus the actual
operators that were used to so to do
that we basically it's going to be the
same right except in it it is basically
going to be exactly the same in terms of
how we actually write it and in terms of
what we're returning and all that stuff
right but one thing we have to know well
one thing we have to note is that when
you're doing something like + yeah it's
quite common to just mark it as
essentially an operator that is in part
of this class so essentially as a friend
okay so
for example if we were to say operator
plus just like that usually you'd market
here after market as a friend but we're
going to mark as a friend it's going to
be in the plus operator and what it's
going to do is is actually going to
taking - okay so this is going to be yes
it'll taking the first it will take in
the left and I'll take in the right okay
so back to left and then back to rice
okay
one of them is going to be normal no
Const no nothing because this is the one
that's actually going to be modified and
then right is going to be the one that
we're reading from if I go into
bacterial CBP and then we take a look we
take a look at this oops vector so we
have so the friends we don't have the
thing we just have operator loss and
then we have vector left constant vector
right so this just means what the side
of the equation is that we're on so if
we could so basically left post right
it's how you kind of use this so what we
need to do is we need to take left we
need to in fact we probably take this in
as a reference but we basically need to
go left or we can even go left dot and
rice just like that okay that's all we
need to do because we've already got the
add method right away rewrite why we
write that code I will actually mark it
as a reference all right cool okay
awesome so there we go
so now in main if we were to go so let's
just say we've got a vector we've got a
vector called a which is 1 & 2 and then
we've got a vector called B which is 2 &
4 yeah why don't you doesn't want you to
say a equals a or rather vector back to
C equals a plus B just like that now
it's important that we know Malthus is a
reference because if we do it won't get
copied so this voice will actually see
will actually be equal to a in this case
which we don't want to happen but that
might be a potentially dangerous thing
to do but we'll leave this like this for
now so if we do run this we should see
so what did we add again so that we
should be three and six right three six
okay fantastic and now you can see we
can actually use this plus operator
which is pretty cool so that is the
general idea of things now let's do the
same thing for all the other operators
so we've got plus minus multiplication
and / division well so let's implement
all these bad boys I'll go ahead and
change these up so this is minus or
subtraction this is multiplication all
times and then this is division and then
we'll just go left don't subtract rights
left dot what am i doing multiply and
then divide one thing I want to mention
quickly is you will see me tossing out
between whether or not to pass things in
as reference and all that means is that
if I pass in something as a reference it
does not get copied the actual object
itself the memory address to it
essentially gets passed in and it is
affecting that same object which is why
if we modify this as we are here right
it will actually change this okay
it will change this left that gets
passed in in this case it's totally
acceptable but again if I do something
like this and then I sets
I said seed of X equal to a hundred
right and I print out a which was the
left part of that thing it will set a
you can see I printed out a but it gave
me a hundred because I was able to
modify a kind of indirectly right so
to do that obviously if I don't mark
this as a reference when I'm on the
receiving end it will get copied into
that variable and this will be fine so
that's just something to think about
when you're designing classes such as
this yeah so we'll leave it like this
again if issues arise I'm going to
revisit this I haven't done a full kind
of plan of how I'm going to do this of
course everything that I've done in
terms of this has been streamed live I
have a workout I never work on this
outside of these streams and these
videos okay
okay cool anyway we've got this so this
is nice but what if I want to be able to
do something like you know I don't want
to have to declare on you like vector
called sea I want to be able to say a
equals a plus B right and that's you
know like I want to add B to a right so
I could either go a dot add B Ryan and
that would be cool but if I want to add
something I don't want to have to go a
equals a plus B in terms of using
operators of course that will work that
will work properly and it will give us
three and six but I want to be able to
say a plus equals B okay
so how do I do that well you have to
overload the plus equals operator so to
do that what we want to do is plus
equals so plus equals is not a friend um
it will return a reference again the
same thing is what this is because
remember we're returning our reference
in the sense that we want to return the
reference to a right and of course we
need to take in B as an actual parameter
so when we call this will call it
operate so plus equals will take in of
course we don't want to modify B at all
so we'll be taking it as a concert
reference again reference because we
don't want to copy it and constant
because we don't want to change it and
then that'll just be I'll put other okay
so that's plastic holes and then I'll do
the same thing for follow it for all the
other ones
okay let's grab one of them let's go
back here okay so now that this this is
an honor this is not a friend so it has
to be in the back to name right and then
all we want to do remember is we just
want to add other to the current object
so essentially what we kind of want to
do is this plus a or this equals this
plus father and then we want to
basically return this that's basically
our game plan so you can do this however
you want you can do it like this so that
will use the operator you can probably
also call add other that might problem
that will probably look a bit more
gracious um and since add will return
this we might as well just return and
other okay and then that will just
basically make it look nice and clean
okay so that's what we can do I'm gonna
same for - and for multiplication and
division so subtract
multiplied my keyboards under my desk
and I can't say it at all by the way so
that's why I'm continually miss typing
because it's like one of those my desks
is one of them has one of those things
where you know at the keyboard kind of
slides underneath the desk and stuff and
I'm kind of trying to sit close to the
microphone so anyway the setup is not
ideal right now well it's it's it is but
it's just it's a bit annoying sometimes
okay a plus equals B so now we should be
able to just add in and we should still
get that same result of three and six
okay let's try something else like minus
something and make sure everything works
- one - two yeah seems legit
multiplication yep and division pretty
cool all right cool
so there you go that is pretty much all
of the vector operations you could
probably need for now in terms of the
point vector I can't think of really any
other ones that would be useful for
vectors at points once you get into
stuff like factors directions and you
want the cross product and you want the
dot product and you know you need all
these functions to calculate angles
between vectors and perpendicular
vectors and well particularly yeah
normals to vectors which is the same as
perpendicular and all that stuff you're
going to need a lot more methods and
we'll probably deal with that once we
get want to maybe stuff like collision
detection and physics and stuff that
actually requires that but for now we
won't deal with that at all all right
cool so that's how it back to to class
fantastic that's pretty much it LOM I
think I don't think I missed anything
Oh equivalence that's a big one so we
want to be able to compare two vectors
so I want to be able to say a equals B
right is that a thing
yeah is a equal to B how do I check that
well I need to obviously overload the
equivalence operator or the comparison
operator
so to do that remember what does it
return a boolean Ryan a return a boolean
result it's going to be the operator
equals equals right and of course we'll
be comparing something else to us so
think of this as just a name so if this
was something like compare yeah put a
dot here and then put brackets here
that's what your function will look like
this is the this is the thing that calls
it this is the name which is the equals
equals and this is the parameter we need
B and then the return value is the
return value so that might be a cool way
to think about it if you guys are new to
operator overloading and you don't
really sure what the syntax is so that's
kind of how it works so what we need to
do is we need to take in a Const back to
other right because of course we're not
going to be modifying other hence the
Const and we don't want to be copying
that data we just want to be reading it
that really in the existing data instead
of copying it so that's why the
reference is there the ampersand and
then all we have to do to implement this
load is copy this prototype we'll go
down here then we'll say bull vector
operator equal Eagles and then we'll
just basically return x equals other dot
x and y equals other dot y all right so
if we print this it should print zero
yes and then if we for example set B B
minus C equals vector one two yeah it
should be 1 okay fantastic
so it works similarly we want a does not
equal operator or you know yeah it does
not equal operator yes so that's pretty
easy to make again it's the same it's
just that it's an not equal to operator
we can copy and paste the prototype here
but remember in order to not rewrite
code all we really have to do is just
return the opposite result of what this
returns so we can just say return not
this equals other okay and that way we
yeah we can we don't have to write the
same code twice so if I run this now we
should get 0 since they
equal and then if I got rid of this line
of code you can see they are okay well
that's true because they are not equal
all right cool
so there we go slowly getting through
this what we're going to do now is
basically copy and paste this a bunch of
times and implemented for Veck threes
and fours and I'm probably going to do
matrix next episode okay because I
probably want to dedicate a whole
episode to that that'll be quite
complicated since we'll be implementing
all of these various things and I don't
want to make these episodes too long
because while that's good for a stream I
don't think that's a great format for
actual YouTube videos so that's what
we'll do okay cool
so let's grab let's um let's open this
on our on our hard drives haven't got
any folder and what I'll do is I'll
simply copy and paste this twice okay so
we'll call this Veck three and then vac
four okay I'll grab om power don't have
to if I go show all files here so I was
already in that mode but if I click the
show all files you can see all these
things have like read kind of things
because they're not included in our
project if we just select all of them
and then hit including project at the
now included in our project so let's
start with vector three of course we'll
change that to a back three I will
basically just go if we here ctrl shift
F makes sure you don't look in the
entire solution make sure you just look
in the current document okay and then we
want to replace anything that says back
to with fact three essentially so let's
replace all cool alright done and then
we'll of course add a Zed this was a big
mistake I don't know why I actually did
that in fact it did work though Lowell
well I'm happy then okay so I guess
we'll get that in there um so we'll have
this we'll have that Zed so we got X Y
Zed now everything else stays the same
here
let's take a look at the CPP file
because that'll be quite different
again we want to do that find/replace so
we're placing avec to with Veck 3 make
sure you're looking in the current
document replace all 47 occurrences done
and that's pretty much it like if you if
we go into here will of course add Z we
will change we will change will have to
add to all of these add methods we'll
have to add the Z components whoops and
well that's not what I meant okay so and
then of course since we have just linked
well since we've just called this code
instead of copying and pasting out we
can just we don't even have to touch
this at all it just works
I took a comparison of course where you
need to add said and of course to the
streaming we want to add to the input
stream we want to add for that okay
and vector Zed and that's yes that
should be it that's all we that's really
all we need to change okay done so let's
do the same for vector for quickly and
then we're done so back for X Y Zed W so
thick fours are useful for for example
colors that's probably the best easy to
explain example if we have RGB a red
green blue alpha all right I don't why
doing this manually so back to replace
move it back for and while we're at it
we'll do the same thing for this
right okay so um yeah we just need to
add two more here
okay um let's see so where are we okay
ah this is done good good
okay ZW everything is coming together
now alright um W is it okay just grab
this and let's paste it here - - and
here and here okay um and then we need
to add to these
and this oh yeah cool there we go so
yeah so everything is looking good right
if we take if we take a look at this now
okay so let's just change this to the
back I'm just good okay we should
probably take the test back three as
well so if we we've got three of these
and I just need to import okay so one
thing I want to mention real quick is
that we've got this thing where if we
want to have all three of the easier we
need to include like three headers being
like vector vector evac four right it's
um it's some massive like just it's it's
kind of annoying and especially once we
have matrix classes everything we just
want to be able to be like I want to
include maths and I'll just include
everything so what we're going to do now
temporarily we want actually pull this
out into some kind of include directory
in the future
but right now we'll make a new header
file called maths right and maths will
be in the maths directory and it will
simply will make sure that it does have
a program once and then we'll simply
including - maths
vector vector a and vector four alright
and once we have matrix one clear that
as well and now all we have to do if we
want all three of these we can just be
like include maths dot H all right
and eventually we'll probably pop that
into like an include directory of its
own so that we can be like include maths
top H or something like that
right but for now we'll just keep it
like this okay cool so now I've got
access to all these so if I change this
now for example and we do something like
this mmm
so let's see and then I go ahead and
let's say what I want to do I just want
to basically print this so let's just
print that out make sure it worked all
night go ahead and say vac three equals
a plus B alpha let's see and everything
will be nice and I'll print C and it
should work and it should give us the
fantastic value of three six eleven okay
which is correct and then you know we
can print B and that'll give us should
give us our original B value and then
we'll print a and then we'll be like
hang on a minute that's not right and
that is because we've done something
very bad in our whoops I just hit the
microphone sorry if something very bad
in our plus operator so if we go back
and take a look at this because what
happened there was actually got modified
a supposed to be one two five but I
changed into three six eleven which is
what the same thing as C is and the
reason that happened is because we took
in a as a reference okay so you remember
how I hesitated there for a minute that
was correct that hesitation so what we
want to do is we do not want to take in
left as a reference okay we just take it
in like this or optionally we could
probably construct some kind of new
object and return it probably not a good
idea though people just taking left as a
copy like this and then if we don't want
to go onto the go into our
implementation file we'll simply get rid
of the reference and it should work
lovely so if I do the same for vector in
work for
that was just a cool convenient exercise
to show you guys that the difference
between references and not references
and whatnot so that all of you people
transitioning from Java into C++ will
have a smooth transition so so yeah but
let's quickly print this now I probably
missed yeah I missed some implementation
ones well okay so where are we yes die
die die die die
it said it I guess we'll see if the
build succeeds us in yes okay so if we
run this we should have 1 to 5 which was
our original value for with my main I'm
in main which was our original value for
this all right fantastic so there we go
that is going to wrap up this episode
I'm gonna quickly check out that for
those so let's just say we did have a
color such as point two this is what I
usually like setting my clear other
thing that's what our clear color is
right now so let's just say it's 0.2 0.3
after 0.9 1.0 if that's likely if a lot
and then I want to I want to add B to it
which cool I'll just make it a bit
different 0.5 to 1 will get the Alpha
the same I can be like effect for C
equals a plus B dot a make sure it's all
good oh here we go
I didn't I did forget it good thing I I
tested this um let's go back here and
remove the reference obviously to match
the header declaration alright cool so
yeah 0.2 0.3 0.8 1 and C of course would
be
NAT which yeah is correct all right and
things are looking pretty good so there
we go
if you have any questions just leave a
comment below those are all of our
vector classes we probably won't be
changing them for a long time until we
move on to more advanced topics such as
physics and when we move on to things
like Ray picking for example and all of
that cool stuff and collision detection
we'll need to add some methods into
these vector classes but for now just
smooth sailing and we'll move onto
matrices next episode so if you guys
have any questions again leave them in
the in the in the comments section below
and don't forget to like the video if
you enjoyed it and I'll see you guys
next time the next time yep I already
mentioned this but matrices so that
should be fun all right good bye
boom boom okay so one last thing that I
forgot to mention before I go is I got
rid of the reference that we had here
when we took in left for all of our
operators however I didn't get rid of
the return value reference this is
important to also get rid of it because
what's happening here is I'm basically
returning a reference left on add
returns left right and then I'm
returning left but left is a copy that
only exists in this curve so I don't
want to be doing man returning local
reference this is a big no-no so I need
to basically get rid of these and just
return a copy of that okay that's all I
need to do so we need to amend that so
over here I'm going to get rid of all
these don't worry about these
intellisense errors it will tell you
it's an error it's it's not so we'll get
rid of all these yeah see like all these
errors like just right-click and go Show
and Tell is show intellisense errors No
okay because we're we just don't maybe
doing that it'll really really annoy you
intellisense sometimes anyway
um enough about that let's get rid of
all these and all of these
and yeah that's pretty much it so back
over here in Maine let's just test this
and make sure everything's good well it
will be but you know we'll test it and
as you can see everything is absolutely
wonderful so that is it I'm ending the
video
for realz now I hope you guys enjoy it
I'll see you tomorrow with matrices good
luck